escapan del cambio climático
decenas de somalíes llegan al campo de
refugiados en Kenia la sequía en su país
ha provocado una grave escasez de
alimentos y agua en múltiples regiones
causando una masiva salida de personas
en busca de Refugio obligados a huir
para sobrevivir los desplazados Aún se
enfrentan a la inseguridad alimentaria y
sanitaria pero ahora en dadaf en los
últimos seis meses hemos tenido un
aumento exponencial de llegadas al campo
desde somalia principalmente la gente
huye de la hambruna y la sequía en el
otro lado también de algunos conflictos
que les hacen cruzar la frontera y venir
a buscar Refugio aquí
somalia enfrenta la peor sequía
registrada en África en más de cuatro
décadas lo que ha desplazado alrededor
de 2 millones de personas en los últimos
dos años durante la sesión del Consejo
de Naciones Unidas para los Derechos
Humanos el cambio climático y la
responsabilidad del organismo para re la
manera de proteger a los más vulnerables
fueron discutidos
nuestras instituciones existen para
promover todos los derechos civiles
políticos económicos sociales y
culturales en igualdad así como el
derecho al desarrollo y el derecho a un
medio ambiente limpio sano y sostenible
estamos en una posición única para
reconstruir este respeto compartido por
la dignidad de los demás
el desplazamiento por causas climáticas
es una categoría migratoria que aún no
ha sido reconocida por el derecho
internacional una laguna en la
legislación que afecta a millones en la
actualidad y que podría condenar a otros
más en el futuro